gracias por estar con nosotros aquí en
france 24 como se ha visto afectada la
erradicación del trabajo infantil en
medio de esta pandemia de coke 19 y la
crisis económica que esto ha traído para
todos los países
pues estamos muy preocupados porque si
el número de niños y de niñas trabajando
en el mundo había disminuido en los
últimos 20 años pero por primera vez en
los últimos 4 años está subiendo está
aumentando de nuevo el número de niños y
de niñas que se dedican al trabajo hoy
día hay
más de 100 160 millones de niños y de
niñas que están trabajando en el mundo
la mayoría en áfrica subshariana eso
significa un aumento de más de 8
millones en los últimos 4 años se debe a
varios factores la pandemia es uno en
áfrica subshariana se ha registrado el
aumento más significativo por la crisis
frecuentes también por el incremento
demográfico y la falta de mecanismos de
protección social pero aún más
preocupante es que en regiones donde se
había registrado un progreso en la
reducción del trabajo infantil como asia
del sureste y américa latina del caribe
se está notando un incremento de la
tendencia precisamente lograr no
hablemos ahora la situación de américa
latina' un nuevo estudio conjunto entre
la oit de la unicef indica que el mundo
no está en vía de eliminar el flagelo
para 2025 y que para cumplir esa meta el
progreso global tendría que ser
casi 18 veces más rápido que en los
últimos 20 años qué tan lejos estamos en
nuestra región de lograr esa meta
pues si no son buenas noticias todos
sabemos que la pandemia ha golpeado
duramente américa latina y el caribe y
ahora lo que vemos es que se está
creando una tormenta perfecta con el
cierre prolongado de las escuelas y
todavía tenemos en la región al día de
hoy 100 millones de niños fuera del
colegio hoy día en américa latina y el
caribe también una alta pérdida de
empleo sobre todo en el sector informal
y un aumento de la pobreza les cuento la
historia de una mamá en bolivia que
antes de la pandemia se dedicaba a
limpiar los zapatos en la calle su hija
iba al colegio estudiaba antes de
lavandería pero como resultado del
confinamiento y de la pandemia la mama
perdió su fuente de ingreso de la noche
a la mañana y ya no le alcanza no le
alcanza el poco de recursos que había
ahorrado y la única alternativa que
encontró es que su hija lamentablemente
deje
estudiarse y se ponga a trabajar a su
lado eso es lo que tenemos que evitar el
trabajo infantil en la región se ha
convertido en un mecanismo de
supervivencia para las familias más
pobres si muy rápidamente logran en un
minuto cuáles son los sectores donde más
se registra el trabajo infantil y cuál
es la recomendación que ustedes le hacen
de los gobiernos si en toda américa
latina y esos son la tendencia que
afecta lamentablemente a todos los
países desde argentina hasta perú desde
república dominicana hasta en mexico
pero los sectores más en riesgo son las
familias más pobres sobre todo en los
sectores informales donde los niños y
las niñas están en el riesgo de caer en
el trabajo infantil entre más duro
y el periodo de cierre de las escuelas
más riesgo corren los niños y las niñas
de caer fuera del pone de nunca volver
al colegio y de caer en el trabajo
infantil